[Music]
the authentic leadership and
facilitation training is a three-day
experience of leadership but leadership
in a way that most of us don't ever get
to experience its leadership that's
authentic it's responsive it's
transparent
[Music]
we have a lot of different types of
folks that attend the leadership
training some are people that have been
in community and are interested in just
making closer friends and getting deeper
some are people that are in work
environments where they want to be able
to bring more of themselves or have more
tools others are leading retreats or
workshops or meetings or anything where
they could just use a space to practice
safely the skills that they're going to
use or are already doing it's a space
for people that are dissatisfied with
the current forms of leadership the
things that cause us to put on a face
over who we are in order to lead a group
of people which then in response makes
the group of people who are leading put
on a face of their own and we get these
interactions where neither of us are
actually being who we are and so it's
unfulfilled on some level and the people
that come were the ones that feel that
unfulfilled mints and have a sense that
maybe there's a different way to do
things and I think they walk out with
that
[Music]
and most of all it's a place to build
community
it's an incredibly welcoming safe and
joyful container where by the end of the
weekend people you've just met will feel
like friends
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on saki on very
excited to be talking about authentic
revolution we have Sarah Ness joining us
on the show hello hi thank you for
coming honest I really appreciate it
yeah super excited for this show that
was a little trailer that summarizes
your authentic leadership training and I
love what you're doing with authentic
revolution I'm very pumped to break this
down with you for those who don't know
Sarah Ness is the founder and chief
catalyst of authentic revolution which
is a consulting and training company for
the skill of honesty within connection
you can find all the links in the by
below to off the Rev dot org as well as
all teams org and enter the living room
check that out too and Sarah necess
YouTube channel highly recommend
watching the video says she's creating
so check all this links out all right
Sarah let's start things off with one of
our favorite questions to ask our guests
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world small question
I'm like tempted to ask like what
section of the direction of the world
but I guess there's a couple different
thoughts as it relates to my own field I
think that like the selves that we are
feel like they're partially inside our
own bodies but they're also the systems
that we've built around us the
technology the social atmospheres and
all of that is expanding and expanding
it's like I don't know what's inside a
computer but I use it to expand my range
of capacity and so we have these like
ever building networks of technology and
self that just feel like they're
increasing exponentially and it feels
like the state of our world is like is
our technology going to increase fast
enough that we can resolve some of the
problems that we've created for our
planet or the problems going to
overwhelm the technology and I think the
thing that's really fascinating to me is
it feels like even as there's a
technological revolution there's also a
social revolution of like understanding
each other more having some concepts on
perspective taking in psychology that
previously were we're only allowed in
psychiatry or different sorts of therapy
settings and now it's like we have so
much information on how people interact
and there's this whole new field that
gets to be explored so I'm pretty
hopeful about it actually yeah big we
love talking about we call it the wisdom
race with the guests that we need to
make sure that our level of
consciousness catches up to the level of
the exponential technology being
democratized around the world and what
that's doing geopolitically and so
things like actually authentic
revolution help our level of
consciousness catch up and so we can win
this wisdom race totally and I think it
even provides a different perspective
like earlier this year I was totally
freaked out about the state of the
environment and the world and it's also
given me the like perspective of okay
like how do I hold the paradox of
wanting the human waste to continue and
acknowledging that like it might not so
what do I do with my day to day life
feels like there's more truth available
yeah
we will not be another collapsed
civilization we will prosper
we will prosper let's get into your
journey all right born in Pennsylvania
move to the University of Texas in
Austin for school and you took a trip
across the u.s. to study intentional
living communities for your senior
thesis thought this was so cool so teach
us about who you were as a kid growing
up and how these things even came up to
fruition in school I feel like a radio
personality like my journey started way
back in Pennsylvania when I was a small
child not gonna be the whole thing in
that voice let's see it so I grew up I
grew up in the suburbs of Pennsylvania
and I grew up pretty isolated I didn't
really understand how social interaction
worked I was like very much on the
fringes of anything involving other
people I spent most of my childhood
reading like on average probably 10
books a week I taught myself to speed
weed because I wanted to weed faster so
I missed the whole bit where people
learned how to interact with others and
when I got to middle school in high
school I realized that I had missed
something and I started kind of trying
to learn a little more about how to how
to interact but wasn't very successful
and got to college and landed in this
real kind of minefield of all sorts of
different personalities I when I was
growing up I was in an all-girls private
school like 30 person graduating class
from sixth grade until twelfth grade so
really like small bubble
and
I'm trying to think of what more to say
the first place that I found where I
felt like I really had a space to expand
was living in a housing co-op because
before then it was like okay I'm living
in places where there's restriction on
my activities like either my parents are
telling me what to do or Ras are telling
me what to do or teachers are telling me
what to do like there was never a place
where I could really figure out like if
I have autonomy what do I choose and the
housing coops are amazing places for
that because it was like a bunch of like
17 to 20 year-olds having to deal with
the finances and the management of a
seventeen person co-op and so I got
really fascinated by like how do people
live together and how do they have to
evolve to actually take responsibility
for themselves
I held a couple officer positions and my
co-op and I ended up taking a year off
of school because I kind of hated school
again that didn't like being told what
to do and I ended up traveling around
for two months and visiting different
intentional communities to try to
chronicle like how are people living
together in college and out of college
and trying to find like collaboration
and communal forms of being and during
that time I stumbled across ecstatic
dance and I stumbled across authentic
relating and it was like this whole
different like okay in the in the coops
one of the things I found was like
communication issues could explode a
house faster than anything if people
started talking behind each other's
backs if people started attacking each
other if there was passive aggression
going on if there were personality
conflicts that didn't have any way to
get resolved then half the house would
leave no matter how beautiful the house
was or the community and there were
other factors like systems and roles and
personal development but a lot of it
felt like communication so when I found
authentic relating it was like oh man
somebody actually developed like some
sort of practice or system that
demystifies communication
and I started leading the games first
with some friends in Houston that
introduced it to me and then at my
housing co-op in Austin it just kind of
took off oh yeah so I like this also
ties us into what you're saying at the
beginning with how so much of our built
environment is based on the way that our
structures are then doing things like
impacting our life so we build things
that then in turn begin impacting our
own life and so when we do things like
learn how to communicate better it makes
it so that when we have problems or
issues that arise that they then get
more easily handled if we know how to do
a good job at walking us through been
studying so much on things like the
Socratic dialogue and method and like
the like scholasticism like things that
are like really old that are that need
to be kind of rebirthed into our culture
including things like this deep dive
into other people's eyes and their life
journeys and who they are and why they
feel the way they do what's developed in
them from their birth until even like
six months of age or just the first
couple years what came with them from
their ancestors until now all of these
things that form a human is critical to
get to know because then you actually
get to know the depths of the psyche and
not just at the surface level and so
then it's cool that by going and picking
up these authentic relating games that
then it it basically makes it easier for
you to go and like seed other people to
authentically relate because it's a game
games are fun people like playing games
and they if they if they can learn
something from the game like how to dive
deeper into human relationships it
impacts their entire all other aspects
of their life can I ask you a question
is this one of the games no I just got
curious I'm actually curious like why
like you said it almost like a universal
good to dive deeper into human psyche
you understand the more like for you why
is that
like what does that give you in relation
to other people well it would be like
jumping into life and staying at the
surface level what do you think that
like what do we think that gives us and
then what do we think okay what if I get
like 25% down into humans what would
that give me 50% down 75% down what if I
got to the extreme depths of the human
psyche like what would that do and like
that that in many ways to be such an
integral part of life but for it might
not be something that is for everyone
although maybe for a vast majority of
people because there are then certain
examples of cases of people that choose
to not dive deep into the psyche and
choose to maybe spend more time in
solitude creating things for the world
just things like that so there's all
different varieties of people but yeah
so maybe like understanding fulfillment
living fully yeah and then also
understanding meaning and purpose more
and helping other people understand
meaning and purpose more understanding
other humans that you don't live here
alone you obviously live here with a
billion others right now and so till I
get to know the other couple five ten
twenty five in your communities and
families that deeper levels will help
you
there's also animals that's - you know
authentic relating on behalf of the
whales that are dying
I have tried circling cats before they
tend to kind of just walk away but I
assume they're just trying to escape
from the intensity so circularly cats
and dogs it's funny yeah um what I love
about what you're speaking to is like
feels like there's communication on the
surface and then there's like why people
are thinking and feeling things and why
they're doing what they're doing like
why you even made the comments about
animals like what's important to you
about that and a lot of the conflicts
that we get into happen on a level of
content instead of process or like
content instead of context that's great
and if you get down to like what are the
person's interests like what is driving
them what do they care about like what's
at stake in this moment
and the first part of that is even
noticing that something something is
there for someone like what's the moment
where somebody where somebody seems to
contract or when their voice gets
excited about something or when their
body language changes you have
principles values the moment that
something happens to the change in
physiology and someone feel something
and then what that changed like you said
context versus process like week you
sometimes go context context context
talk talk talk talk talk but not
necessarily go well why is that person
feeling that way like let's dive into
the life journey and understand their
process that got them to there yeah so
then let's let's give some examples of
this because so then after you picked up
this these authentic relating games you
have you founded the authentic
revolution community about seven years
ago let's let's also clean what
authenticity means got it
I've been writing some on this recently
because authenticity feels like it's
it's a word that's used all over our
culture these days right
there's like authentic metalworking and
authentic Seattle on authentic you know
self and whatever it is and I think
everyone's defining it differently and
often how authentic you are becomes a
bar to measure yourself against like are
you being true to yourself like are you
actually following your desires and in
my world it's like there's no
inauthenticity
like if authenticity is honesty with
oneself then like at all times we're
being as authentic as we can possibly be
we're showing as much of ourselves as we
feel comfortable to the outside world
and all the different parts of ourselves
are showing up in the exact degree that
they're able to so if I think of
authenticity as just like oneself that I
can have more or less of at any given
moment then it's hard to figure out like
how to show more of myself but if I
think of authenticity as multiple
different aspects of myself like I have
a self right now that's like kind of
gauging how I'm talking and is it clear
enough and I have a self that's like
excited about what I'm speaking about in
a self that's like tracking what's
happening for you in a self that's aware
of the audience out here and you know
all of those are showing up in different
proportions mm-hmm so authenticity to me
becomes what's more important even as
awareness like how much can I see of the
different parts of myself and then how
much choice can I have over which ones
I'm showing like can I choose to breathe
past the discomfort of not knowing what
I'm saying moment to moment and choose
to focus on like who might be out there
or what might be happening for you so
it's like seeing and then choosing what
I'm gonna show in any given moment
rather than assuming that there's a more
or less authenticity that I can have
mmm okay so you see all of the different
will you who know yourself well so maybe
I think to see them starts with knowing
oneself really well one's own deepest
meaning or purpose in life and then then
being really aware of all of the
possibilities that exist in the space
and then you kind of like are very aware
of all different possibilities and then
you collapse the one the future that you
want to choose on a moment-to-moment
basis right and there's like
authenticity with what I'm feeling and
what I want in any given moment which
might be if I'm feeling nervous I want
to like not talk but there's another
authenticity which is my values and what
I care about and if I if I find this
integrity this alignment between like
what I care about how I'm showing up how
I'm speaking how I'm acting that I think
is what people often talk about when
they talk about authenticity is what I
sometimes call congruence like am I
being an accurate representation of what
matters most to me and that takes a lot
of work because there are different
parts of me that feel different things
and it's it's really hard in a culture
especially that tells us to like do what
we love and follow our desires when
those may not actually align with what
we care most about I like that word a
lot I like the word congruence it's like
if you're pursuing your truest highest
self your deepest meaning and purpose in
life you can feel a higher degree of
congruence with that on a
moment-to-moment basis it also you you
kind of broke this down I think in a
very interesting way that are it's both
part of our our own nervous system with
the way that we've taken inputs and then
compute that and make sense of what
choice we want to go in the future but
you broke it down by even the different
ways that we're seeing something like
this like you said that you you have
part of yourself is really being
vigilant with the words you use another
party for social super excited another
part of your social wondering how I'm
feeling you know the part of yourself
wondering how the audience is feeling
when you know that all those things are
happening at the same time you become
more well-rounded person versus if you
only have one of those things in mind or
none or maybe your sewin flow that you
know they're all happening but you're
just channeling your the moment and they
psyche which is the most fun part of it
but kind of hard to get to this heart is
really hard to be in flow in congruence
all the time yet I hate that I think the
thing that stops flow in congruence most
ashamed because if I have different
parts of myself and there's one that I'm
ashamed of like if I feel nervous but
I'm not okay with that
mmm I'll kind of subconsciously shut it
down but it will go away it just exists
under the surface and it kind of causes
some tension in my body and then I can't
look at the tension because I've already
told myself it's not there so I'm being
affected by something I can't see and
then that is actually really like subtle
and painful and shows up in all sorts of
places in my life so the thing that I've
really been trying inauthentic relating
recently and one of the reasons I like
the practices is it basically goes okay
rather than finding the parts of
yourself that are okay and not okay
let's look at the fullness of who you
are and see if we can like make all that
okay to exist because it does like
that's what's happening in reality like
that's the person you are and the more
you can see about it the more choice you
have about it
there's I think you know we should
definitely talk about loneliness as well
I think this is another good one to to
what is what does the work have to do
with loneliness in today's world yeah so
it ties into why I think people come to
authentic relating games and like I said
in the video there's a pretty wide
variety of people that come
I would almost be hard-pressed to find
an audience that like hasn't shown up at
authentic relating games at some time or
another from like you know oil rig
workers from like West Texas to you know
Austin hippies to like engineers to
computer people all sorts of folks and a
pretty wide age range usually from teens
to like we've had people up intercept
into their 70s and 80s and in part I
think it's just people come because
connection is a unifying factor but the
rates of loneliness and our culture in
general have increased exponentially in
the last couple of decades there's one
study that I think the number of
confidence that Americans have have gone
down like from from like three to one in
the last couple of decades and
loneliness has been associated with like
rates of death on on the level of life
smoking a pack of cigarettes a day like
there's this growing body of evidence
that shows us that that being lonely not
having human connection is detrimental
to our health and happiness but
something that I found was after I
graduated college like college put me in
contact with other people I couldn't
avoid them there were other people in my
classes I'd bump into other people in my
dorms and then the coop there was this
ready-made community for me and when I
graduated it was like kind of this
desert
like I could go on Facebook or I could
you know do online dating or I could
maybe attend a meetup group but like who
would I go with and it was like there
were so many choices and none at all
and I don't think people do well with a
lot of choices especially when none of
them feels particularly appealing so the
reason that I think I'm oh I got really
passionate about authentic relating was
I saw people walking in and having this
experience of actually feeling
connection because the games kind of
artificially induce a sense of
connection that usually only happens in
long-term friendships they basically
make it safe for us to be honest and
vulnerable with each other and that's
what it feels like when you've been in
connection with someone for several
years as you know you can show different
parts and you won't be shut down
you can like hang out with someone for
several years and never look at their
eyes for a minute straight but if you
just jump into a stranger's eyes for a
minute straight exactly people
experience this moment of like whoa okay
like I can have something I can have a
relief from loneliness that I didn't
know I could and for some people if
that's just like what I call a reference
experience like something that happens
once and then they take it out and look
for it in the world great if they never
come back like but they get what they
need that's awesome and for some other
people it's not what they need at all
they have that in their life already or
they're not interested in it I have
members of my family that are like not
into this stuff it's not their form of
communication and that's fine but for
some people there's this this space that
they can go and actually have a sense of
human human connection
and I think that's really needed in our
culture at the moment
yeah they hate you ah yeah you know
there's it's a lot about loneliness that
it's it almost it makes it so that our
our hearts feel it and it it's something
that like we want everyone to be able to
experience a deep love and connection to
other humans and yeah yeah and it's also
interesting how metropolis is affect
loneliness and how they also affect
network effects and how villages around
the world affect don't have a network
effect but may not have loneliness hmm
you give up some individuality to be
together with a group of people but I I
don't know if the loss of individuality
is worth the loss of happiness that
comes from not being connected to others
and I think we've gone far enough that
it's not always a choice unless we're
really intentional about looking for it
Trust trust is a hard part yeah of
community because people are lacking
this authenticity within themselves and
if they're not true to themselves
they're not gonna be true to others it's
a very interesting species we've evolved
into the way I think of it these days is
like if out of a hundred people one or
two are legitimately psychopaths like I
think there are people out there who
will manipulate others will try to hurt
others generally the only ones I found
her ones with actual psychological
disorders that have them not feel
empathy in the same way but that exists
but if one or two out of a hundred
people are gonna be that and I
generalize the lack of trust all the
rest of that hundred people then I live
a pretty isolated life so the intention
for me has become like not how do I like
keep enough of myself back that I'm safe
but actually how do I develop emotional
resilience so if I do get hurt it
doesn't it doesn't matter as much to me
it's such a good way to put it yeah and
that speaks really well to do what Ron
just said that that carrying ourselves
with the with a like a passion for
emotional resilience and bringing
ourselves fully into the world and and
making it really clear to other people
that we give people trust right off the
bat and then we still stay careful with
like understanding how people like give
us trust back and we see all those
relationships form because if there is a
time when there is a moment where that
may get violated that we have a strong
emotional resilience to see that
understand it bounce back from and keep
going forward
yeah and the thing that's been really
cool for me about authentic relating is
that like it doesn't decrease the
chances or the pain of being
misunderstood by someone else or having
a conflict with someone else what it
gives are tools for how to stay in
connection when that happens
I just had a work call before this where
like there was a lot of tension among
the leadership team that I was working
within but the thing that was different
was like we could stop and call out like
hey it seems like you're uncomfortable
with this like it doesn't seem like
you're a hell yes - moving forwards and
I'm not comfortable so like would you
say what's going on with you perfect so
it's like that that capacity to actually
sit in the discomfort fine connection
within it almost always creates some
sort of resolution or even if the
resolution is we're not gonna see eye to
eye yeah yeah that's so badass to be
able to it is it's like you know right
now you know being live can you say like
you know can you stretch your jaw if you
need to you know you know okay yeah you
know can you can you do things that some
people may consider to be weird like if
three people are talking and one of them
is like not feeling hell yest and we can
move in the direction that the other two
want to go just say hey feels like it's
not a hell yes for you to move like how
are you feeling right now mm-hmm
how you feeling right now how you
feeling right now you know these are not
hard questions it's so easy to ask you
know how are you feeling right now and
that can feel like oh wow they
recognized me and now I have space to
say how I feel and then you talk about
it and then you figure out what's the
best move of action right and and I
think the difficult thing about that is
asking a question like that most people
see is socially inappropriate because
conversations flowing a certain
direction to ask a question like that
basically puts a roadblock in it right
it's like you take agency to change the
direction of conversation most people
are uncomfortable with that so the big
games the authentic relating games the
reason that I like them is they give us
safe spaces to practice things that are
socially unacceptable like asking the
questions you're genuinely curious about
or revealing your motivation for saying
something or speaking to a feeling that
you're having with someone else or
sharing your impression of them
yeah let's give a demo of these so
there's actually over 150 of these at
this point yeah at this point of these
authentic relating games and these
happen at the workshops that authentic
revolution is hosting they happen at yes
authentic revolution and there's like 70
plus communities around the world that
we've helped start some of them but the
cool thing is like there we're all
independent and di2 around if you want
to bring it up we have a wave a little
law there's a map yeah we have a little
map of so many different ones on the
east coast of the United States and the
Midwest on the west coast of the US a
lot in Europe tons and Europe too yeah
conversations about honesty authentic
Sweden circling centre mindful learning
authentic relating Boston authentic
relating New York San Diego authentic
relating and circling and these are only
the ones I know about like there's
probably 15 to 20 more since I made I've
been trying to update this map but
there's so many that I can't keep track
of them yeah
that's so cool yeah okay so then these
gif end of relating games are happening
across but we're circling which is a
related community yeah yeah so there's
like this decentralized network but the
other cool thing is like the games
happen within communities they happen
within workshop settings but they also
are just like little modules that you
can take like I've played these at
family gatherings I've played these at
workplaces I've played these like to
start off a conversation I was hiring
somebody the other day and I said okay
to start with I'd love to just like play
five minutes of curiosity you get to ask
me anything you want for five minutes if
I don't want to answer I'll just say no
so like feel free to use your curiosity
and then we switched and it was like the
best way to do a job interview it got so
much out of the way right at the
beginning oh cool mmm-hmm yeah the
strength of the questions are really
important is you got to do things that
are not surface you know about like the
weather or the sports or yeah do you
want to play one yeah yeah let's play
one of the games yes which one are we
gonna play
mmm also reminds me of childhood I love
the idea of play you know yeah yeah it's
so good um let's play so kind of the
granddaddy of games is called noticing
noticing which is like a simple body
awareness one so we'll do that and then
I want to end with like a bit of like a
deeper question okay so the way noticing
works is we go back and forth and say
being with you I'm noticing okay and
noticing you can notice anything that's
happening in the present moment so often
times it works well if you're noticing
like physical sensations or emotions
things that are affecting you but you
can also notice things that you're
seeing in the other person so whatever
is arising in the moment within you or
what you're seeing in the other person
yeah and the only thing that's different
and yeah we're the environment like okay
it's kind of like the subtext of like
what else is happening and of course in
any moment there's ten different things
going on so feel free to also choose
like sometimes I look for like what's
the one that's affecting me most yeah so
we just go back and forth because I'm
noticing being with you I'm noticing
okay and you're welcome to take a second
to respond if you okay
it's okay cool and then we always start
with being with you I'm noticing you and
also just say I'm noticing or are
sometimes hearing that I'm noticing
hearing oh yeah okay cool okay I'll
start okay being with you I'm noticing
delight and vulnerability hearing that
makes me feel really good yeah
hearing that I feel curious and I'm
noticing your smile
your curiosity makes me feel like we're
at place having this conversation
hearing that I'm thinking about the game
structure
mmm hearing that I'm wondering what have
been the most profound things that have
happened from this game of noticing ever
in the history of the game
hearing that I want to respond and I'm
also feeling like delighted at your
expression hearing that it makes me want
to express so much more just like the
most expressions ever hearing that I
just had this like vision of you as like
a little kid like wow hearing that it
makes me think about the social fabric
of our world and how we how much it at
times inhibits the exfoli Phylis
expression of children
hearing that I noticed myself slowing
down and having like a a wider
perspective like all of a sudden them
even noticing more things in the room
yes last one okay hearing that wider
perspective I'm thinking about the ways
that we can update the social fabric to
make it better for children to express
themselves yeah thank you thank you yeah
something I noticed just as like a
little bit of meta like looking at what
happens something I notice about that
game is like it's like we get to have a
conversation on ten times the speed like
all the the kind of like flow of getting
excited and then like kind of calming
back down and then would they'd probably
a point where we get excited again and
like Oh
interpersonal to world to self that was
cool yeah that's a good meta perspective
Thanks you get like a compression the
games act as a compression algorithm for
all the different feelings of life yes
and worldview statuses the way I think
about it is like if conversation is a
stream the games like put a dam in the
stream and so the water builds up in a
certain part and it means that like you
just get like more intensity and you get
to really explore something more deeply
and then when you let the barrier go
there's a lot more flow possible can I
add can I do one more yes okay so the
thing that I'd love to share in here
just to kind of get deeper connection
with you is to give a couple of answers
to the sentence stem and oftentimes will
say sentence 10 which is like kind of
like a question but a sentence to fill
in sentence stem a sentence stem yeah
it's it's like a question but it's like
the start it's like a prompt the start
disowning so okay for example though one
I'd love to do is like what I think I
get about you is oh that's a good one
yeah what I think I understand about you
okay
do you want to go first or today yeah
I'll go first what I think I understand
about you is your passion for the depth
of the psyche oh and the thing the thing
I love adding to this is a one to five
scale of like how much that fits so I'm
just gonna show you with my fingers so
and one being least in five being most
okay okay and then so the person does
that afterward that's cool yeah I like
doing it that way you also play it with
what's out there
I like that feedback that's good yeah I
think that's really good so I'll German
um something I think I get about you is
that you have like a wider perspective
on human nature that you connect a lot
of things back to and that there's a lot
of importance and meaning to you in the
world and how it's going and your effect
on it yeah for sure
yeah
okay
something that I that I think I'd get
about you is that when someone has these
deep moments of awakening with an
authentic relating are some of your most
beautiful moments in your life
something I think I get about you is
that you seem like fairly analytic like
I imagined your primary like center
through which you run things is more
your head than your heart but I think
that you've trained your awareness of
feeling and response to others yeah
that's that's probably really high true
yet yeah maybe like four and a half or
so four or five four five just because
I've also spent now a decent amount of
time now working on meditation and
working on connecting my body in my
heart and other people's bodies hearts
some spirit to spirit as well all that
is going out that broad unbounded
feeling yeah like keeping one foot in
analytical in one foot and all that is
you know it's kind of funny
so can we can we do one last what about
Vaughn yeah please yeah let's get it you
want to do me oh yeah
Ron I think you have a naturally playful
personality and I think that one of the
things you like about this show is you
get to like play the character of
yourself
he's given a fire
put the good on Farah and now I have to
if you want to give one I think you
should give one for Allen actually
because you know him I've just met y'all
it's hard because we're I know a lot of
I think I know a lot about him Alan
the thing I realize about you or I think
I know about you is you're not fully
human the your body is a mere vessel for
something beyond our comprehension
yeah it's very accurate it's fine yeah
I'm trying to figure that out more and
more
Ron Ron has been a major catalyst in me
understanding forces that are happening
beyond our 3d reality and and now other
people and stories have been popping up
as well of people being vessels or
channels that other forces are at play
through them on the planet and so yeah
it almost feels as though you can feel
the fight happening within you sometimes
between the forces but you can get
called you're trying to get like pulled
by some of the more malevolent forces to
like get distracted and like get away
from your like life purpose and it's
like it's like this far and you have to
get to this point to tip over into the
malevolence and for like the next hour
two of your time but then you like catch
yourself right here and you're like get
away from me yeah and then you focus on
the positive and you keep building what
you're doing I don't necessarily believe
that and the forces are benevolent or
benevolent it's just it's just the
simplicity of light and dark and the the
the malevolence yeah it has a big factor
in in the benevolence of it all and it's
the evil only comes out of what our this
primitive process that you know we're so
primitive and we just we lean maybe
towards the darker side it's not
necessarily evil however when we're not
we're not living in balance so there's
not money you know there isn't good guys
bad guys it's just positive negative
dark light you know evil is our creation
with what we do with it when we know
that we really shouldn't be doing this
but we do it anyway you know which we
have a gut instinct that we go against
and that's that's what is evil we are
evil
there's not you know beyond this is just
yeah this is and this is whatever coming
to conclusion with but the evolution of
my understanding because I recall Alan
telling you all this does is it dark
villain amount out there Darth Vader is
upon us you know we need to be careful
but you know all we need to do is look
in the mirror to see just God and devil
it's it's right there it's right outside
your door know now testify so you get to
deep conversations like this with other
people through these games and let's go
through the names of the games again
what was the first one we played first
one was noticing noticing just noticing
Kay and then the second one was the
second one was a sentence stem sentence
staff Fenton system there's a whole ton
of these in the game's manual actual
actually different questions down the
game's manual on the website yeah it's
by donation by donation get downloading
back games manual and get playing it in
with your friends and communities I love
that that's great and be weird be ready
that it may be that your friend there's
some of your friends may not want to do
it from your family may not want to do
it so it's totally cool to find other
people that want to do it and play it
with them because otherwise that's like
your test of faith if you don't pass
that then you won't get to play what do
you mean sometimes you get a test of
faith like oh I download this manual now
I'm here with my family are there was a
couple friends and they're like this is
lame we don't want to do this we don't
want to get full narrable we don't want
do this stuff and then you're like ahhh
and then you stop but if you're like oh
that's a test of faith now I have to go
and find other people that I don't know
that want to play this stuff I love that
perspective on it yeah I think of family
as like the final test it's like the
boss battle yeah it's like family and
boss or like yeah boss at work like it
is like a boss battle right cuz there's
so many like dynamics and hierarchies
and your role and your family and are
you challenging that I have a funny
story about this actually if you yeah
yeah give us a short story okay
think they'll be ok with me sharing this
but
so I had an experience trying to bring
these games to my family or like trying
that I was trying to relate with my
brother and we went to Burning Man
together and I was so he and I he went
to boarding school when I started middle
school about so we didn't really grow up
together and we our relationship when I
was young was like really bad and so I
was like okay this is my big chance to
get to know my brother for the first
time and I was like pulling out all the
stops like I was like asking great
questions and I was sharing phoner ibly
about myself and I was like you know
everything I knew how to do I was being
present with him I was connecting and
the thing about my brother is he's
absolutely brilliant and he's a very
private person like he lives kind of in
the middle of nowhere with one person
and and he doesn't like sharing things
intimately about himself until he feels
very comfortable with someone and we
didn't have that deep of a relationship
yet so I was trying to communicate with
him in this authentic relating mode and
it just wasn't landing and there was
this period like in the middle of the
burn where like we're having this
incredibly intense conversation to the
point where like I had to run away for
ten minutes and just break down behind a
car it was like I didn't know if our
relationship was gonna come back from it
and about like a couple weeks later he
comes through Austin with his girlfriend
now fiancee and I prepared this time I
was like okay if I were to relate with
him from his language because it's not
about just authenticity it's also about
relating the mirroring yeah and like
deep questions aren't the only way to
relate like yeah for me it's actually
about figuring out like what language is
someone else speaking how do I meet them
where they're at and so I was like okay
my brother like he loves talking about
different topics he's super
knowledgeable he's one of the most
well-read well-informed people that I
know he likes experiences and so I was
like okay how do I speak his language
and so I just all day like you know took
him and his girlfriend around town and
we went and saw the sights and we got
ramen and we you know like I asked about
topics and stuff
and we had these great conversations and
I felt a little bit out of my depth I
was like whoa I don't know how to relate
like this but I'm gonna try to learn
because he tried to learn mine and so we
get to the evening and we're having a
beer together at a coffee shop and he
turns to me and he goes okay you've been
good you can ask us deep [ __ ] yeah and
it was it was validating it was like
okay like I need to meet someone else in
their world before I ask them to come to
mind like recently yeah yeah that's how
you do it you speak in the language of
other people you mirror and that's part
of NLP neuro-linguistic programming yeah
it's totally a part of that and you can
use the games to figure out what someone
else's language is yep
like there's skills underlying the games
which is a lot of what I try to teach
these days and those can be used in any
situation even if the games themselves
can't be yeah can we take a question
from the audience yes please
Kendall asked he's curious what she sees
as the growing edge of the authentic
relating where it is growing or what she
sees in terms of where it is moving what
direction the growth is in o of the
movement as a whole yes
okay okay so that mm-hmm sweet I didn't
know we had a live audience this is cool
no thanks for watching right so
authentic relating just as a little bit
of backstory when I found it it was like
maybe five communities came out of San
Francisco in the early 1990s moved to
Boulder where there was a hub when I
learned it around 2012 and now there's
you know like seventy plus communities
so there's a real a real like form of
growth in formerly it was just in
community building and how to like how
do we have hoops together and I would
like host calls like community
mastermind calls for the leaders to
relate and interact and now in the last
couple years there's been a movement
towards bringing authentic relating into
other places so there's quite a number
of people that are doing consulting with
businesses or are working with schools
or are bringing it into prison
even now with authentic relating
international there's quite a few
communities in San Francisco that are
using it the rationalists communities
and I think the real edge right now is
how do we translate vulnerability
authenticity empathy into other
languages into other cultures and when I
speak about other cultures I don't just
mean other countries I mean like
families businesses of different kinds
schools communities I was in Malaysia
recently working with a company and
trying to figure out how do I learn
their culture quickly to be able to
bring these things in so I'd say that's
that's one cutting edge on like a kind
of instrumental scale and then on on an
internal scale
I'm not really sure actually like I want
to have a pat answer to that but I think
different communities are working with
different things there's kind of a life
cycle that people go through with
authentic relating which is like they
have a default way of being and this is
vastly generalized but default way of
being find authentic relating go oh man
I can be honest with more parts of
myself and people actually want to hear
it and they go out to their life and
they try to do it with everyone around
them and people are like woah okay like
what is this there's no context to it
people are just trying to express more
of themselves it screws with a lot of
relationships sometimes like people's
friend groups entirely change or you
know they just an account or a lot of
conflict and so then there's another
phase of learning how to speak other
people's languages and like what parts
of myself are most important to show if
if like showing all of me is gonna be
rejected in some situations but but I
don't think people can get to the
relating piece without going through the
authenticity because you have to know
what's in there by kind of making
mistakes by going too far towards the
pole that you haven't been in to
calibrate back towards the center so
there's this kind of pendulum swing that
people go through and I think that where
the authentic relating movement is now
is having as a movement swung kind of
far towards that authenticity and now
trying to come back towards the relating
of like how do we integrate this into
mainstream society into other forms of
communication in life yeah and then
hopefully bring society as a whole a
little bit more on the realm of
authenticity yep
that's a great way to put it and then
getting it into schools and getting into
the corporations so critical I love
those yeah thanks Kendall was a good
question great question
what does it mean that constraint
creates depth
the river was one metaphor for this
trying to think of another one day I
mean yeah basically that like whenever
you whenever you cut off some options I
think of this sometimes in terms of
creativity like I'm more creative often
if I give myself a form to work in like
if I say I'm gonna sit down and write a
poem there's so many possibilities of
what I could write about that I get
overwhelmed but if I sit down and I go
I'm gonna write a haiku what am i
inspired by right now I'm gonna write a
haiku about simulation series and its
effect on the world it's like I have
this more defined channel to work with
it yeah
where I can be wildly creative okay but
I need I need a topic and so the games
what they do is they is that how I think
we have that in most areas of our life
but often not in conversation unless
there's a specific topic but if you go
to a party it's like what there's this
whole field of like what are you
supposed to talk about with other people
who are you supposed to talk to and I
think the thing get people that people
get overwhelmed by like what causes
social anxiety is too many choices like
we're not built for that many and so to
have a game to have an artificial with
social constraint has a lot of people
feel a lot safer mmm and then if you
practice with them that safe constraint
then you can start putting it out more
like I grew up with really severe social
anxiety which is a lot of why I got into
authentic relating like even now like
every time I'm in a room with others
like I have so much physical tension in
my stomach I can't stand up like I have
to sit down I have to like often
meditate for a while before I go and
talk to people sometimes it'll take an
hour or two to fade
and the games have kind of gradually
expanded my capacity to stay with that
sensation more and more and to know like
what to talk about
even wallet in that
yeah I spent a decent amount of time
also remembering your story about your
brother and speaking in the language of
your brother can unlock and move people
further in the direction of the
authentic relating yeah I like that a
lot
okay and it totally makes sense people
feel it all the time when they have
something to do and that they really
squeeze the amount of time they have
left before it needs to be deployed and
then they feel like they're those are
the constraints and they can really get
creative in that time yeah you give a
good example that poem too what about
the balance between authenticity and
relating what does anyone mean that
speaks to so I'm going to track back of
like when we're kids I think that we we
have this whole range of how we can
express that's somewhat defined by our
personality growing up but like we start
out like pretty much all nature and then
we get nurture as we grow up and we
start expressing different things like
maybe as a kid I thought a temper
tantrum how my parents respond to that
and how my friends in the environment
respond to that shapes how much I think
I can doing that part of myself so if I
show anger and my parents are actually
like really encouraging like yeah
express your boundaries then I grew up
thinking that like actually probably
having a fairly healthy expression of
anger because I might see it as like how
to express my boundaries if I go up in a
situation where anger where I see anger
around me and it's something that's used
to hurt others then I might either shut
down my own anger or or react by being
more angry or if my parents shut down my
anger if they're like that's not an OK
expression or stop crying then either I
get more angry or I also shut down my
own emotion and think it's not okay so
we have this mirroring from our outside
environment when we're young that I
think shapes a lot of our emotional
reality when we get older that's how we
interact with the world but there's so
many different types of people and
they've all been shaped by different
environments
and we're kind of in this confusing
space of like I don't know if you want
me to communicate with you directly or
indirectly or like to be softer and more
emotional or more analytical and it's
like how do I figure that out so I get
to train that by like being honest like
the best way I know have to do that is
let me show a little bit more of some
part of myself like let me raise my
voice a little get a little more intense
and see how you respond and you're
nodding so it's like okay cool I can
bring a little more of my intensity here
but I'm not just expressing I'm also
like watching for your response or
asking about it and there's these two
poles of like how much do I want to show
of my own self-expression
can I push the boundaries so I have a
little bit more space in places where
historically I didn't feel okay but can
I also do it and stay attuned to you and
one of my when one of my teachers
Michael Porcelli likes to say that
there's a spectrum between expression
and ownership so the more I go towards
owning my experience towards like
speaking calmly and an I statements and
like saying things of like you know I'm
angry right now and I'm feeling upset
that you did this thing that's ownership
and anger is just like how could you
like how could you do that
it's totally unknown but it's actually
more more honest or authentic in a way
to what I'm feeling like I shut down a
little bit of like what's really
happening in order to own it so there's
it's kind of like where am I playing
along that scale and I'm not gonna be as
aware of you if I'm expressing fully we
lose some consciousness of the other
person when we're more in our own
expression so either I try to pay
attention to both of us at the same time
authenticity and relating or I go more
fully into you to relate and ask about
your experience or I go more fully into
me and express and the best way to like
check which one to do is to set context
which is like sometimes I'll just ask
someone like hey can I can I set a
five-minute timer and just be unfiltered
and I want like I'd love it if you just
like don't take anything I say is truth
like I'm upset at you I just want to be
able to speak
so it's not on my chest anymore I'd love
to just hear afterwards like what
impacted you about that and I can give
myself the space to go full into
expression as long as the other person
knows what's coming and they've
consented to it
a lot of words that's another good
exercise to be so aware that you can ask
that exact question if I can do a
specific style of communication with you
for a period of time to see to help me
express to see how you react but I do I
wonder if one can carry a authenticity
and relating at the same time as they go
about the world and then kind of like
figure out what works for each person
and then tailor themselves if you can
wear like a lot of different costumes
and like put on different outfits for
each person yeah I actually like I
didn't hold that perspective and then a
friend brought that to me a little bit
ago and really had me think about it and
I think like there are moments when I
hold both of them and for me it's mostly
if I'm in a flow state like I can be
conscious of myself and the other and
it's kind of we're both just contained
within a more universal self I'm still
trying to learn how to do it like in
daily life yeah me too yeah I was hoping
you had the answer always a student of
the universe there's yeah the only thing
I know is that I know nothing all right
how about now it's this is the authentic
leadership training has happened over
500 different leaders you express it
there's like 75 more of these
communities now around the world what
does it mean when these people are then
leading from truth
it's a couple different things one is
this idea of more congruence when a
leader gets up in front of a room and
they look at it a whole bunch of people
it feels like there's a choice in that
moment you can like launch straight into
the plan that you have and just run that
beginning to end regardless of what's
happening in the room
or you can go a little more into
awareness and go what's happening in me
what seems to be happening in other
people and either you might run the same
plan but reveal a little more like give
personal examples to things rather than
examples from stories that you've heard
or share in the moment like I'm feeling
like really really like excited about
what's happening in this room right now
or ask about people on a personal level
like hey I noticed that seemed to impact
you like will you share what's going on
with you with the group you might even
choose to change a leader acting from
authenticity might even choose to change
their plan I sometimes tell my students
like hold your plan lately and your
intention strongly yeah so have a
compass so you know what you want people
to get out of what you're doing that's
really important but the way you get
there can be guided by what you're
attentive to in yourself and in others
and to do that you have to be aware and
awareness is vulnerable when you're both
a bunch of people because you don't know
what's gonna happen next and that a lot
of the training is is getting people
into practicing that space of being
aware questioning their reactions trying
new things getting feedback directly
about how it lands and coaching about
like how to make their natural way of
being the superpower they bring to the
world yeah before going in and just
operating an algorithm like breaking
breaking bread at the table with other
people you know slow everyone down and
express deep gratitude for each other
for the food check in with how people
are feeling maybe have a couple words
before you dig in type of thing same
thing with a meeting at work like
instead of getting in there with an
agenda and just boom boom boom boom
doing it just be like how do I feel how
does the room feel let's talk first us
emotionally connect and then jump in and
I mean those are the dets the difference
between leaders that are known by the
people that they work with as as once
they really appreciate that they can
dive deep into emotionally so
relationships with versus once that feel
like their fear approaching
social-emotional context it's all about
logic and productivity and getting
things done so yeah big differences
there
what's the authentic life course I'm
actually gonna take a breath first yes
hmm
Thanks
in the test there was like this peak of
energy earlier and now it feels like
we're kind of like coming down into a
softer space yeah there's part of me
that's like oh no we're losing the
energy but actually it feels just like a
calmness but I need to sell myself down
to enjoy it
it's like I'm putting the head on the
shoulder yeah it's like the nap after
you get all excited so from the nap
space yeah the authentic life course
something I noticed is that people that
came to authentic relating or weekend
workshops of any kind like dance events
yoga retreats transformational events
would have these really big amazing
experiences but then go home and not
know what to do about it and our social
and physical environments shape a lot of
who we are yeah so people need or it all
most folk fool to send people home
without some tools of how to integrate
this into life so the authentic life
course is meant to teach the principles
off of authentic relating and give a way
to practice them such that they can
actually be integrated into people's
daily lives so it's a nine week online
course that goes over things like how do
you become aware of what's happening
around you how do you take agency in
social situations to change things how
do you ask deeper questions how do you
make active versus passive requests of
people around you how do you get
feedback from people in your life about
how you show up there's an exercise in
it where people ask like five to ten
people they trust in their life a set of
questions like how do you see me what do
you trust me for what do you not trust
me for and and get reflection sometimes
for the first times yeah it also goes
into like emotional resilience how do
you be okay if someone doesn't want your
authenticity what do you do then yeah so
it's it's kind of an attempt to clarify
those topics and have it be really
experienced aware there's videos so
people learn about it they do personal
practices and then they actually have
assignments to try it in their life
excellent and there's there's also the
authentic leadership trainings happening
in Mont and Reno Boulder and one in
Austin that's called the living room
that's coming up yeah that's actually
not a Leadership Training the living
room the living room is okay I'm gonna
take a second with this one it's
actually kind of a vulnerable one
because it's like it's one of those ones
where it's like okay I feel a little
like an impostor for putting this on
like am i cool enough to do this for the
type of people that are that are coming
but it's kind of like a more intuitive
like oh this seems like what I care most
about and where I want to go which is
the living room is is like a conference
that is bringing together people that
work at the intersection of
consciousness or relating work whether
it's authentic relating nonviolent
communication
pretty I'm trying to think of others
dance there's dancers coming their
systems experts there's scientists
people that are working at like
consciousness and also doing things out
in the world to apply it because I think
you can work just at the level of how do
I create deeper relationships in my life
or how do I like doing this just one on
one or like have dreams of what I want
to do but then there are people that are
working in this delicate space and like
I care about how I'm connecting with
other people I'm aware of myself and
then I'm also trying to do something in
the world and I and often those people
don't have a lot of others around them
that are that are working in that same
space like they've developed so many
parts of themselves that it's hard to
find others that can beat all of them so
the living room is an experiment in
bringing everybody in that field
together and it's inviting application
only so we're pretty careful about
screening it and bringing them together
for three and a half days in Austin at a
really beautiful retreat space and just
creating spaces for skill sharing for
conversations for deep connection and
relaxation and lots of like surprise and
mischief and getting us out of our
comfort zones into the full potential of
who we are as bodies spirits as
relational beings as creators bringing
that together cool the conference is
soon September that's coming yeah first
weekend of September and then speaking
of spirits do you think we come from
somewhere else beyond this 3d reality
into these flesh vehicles to play on
planet Earth
oh man
I hold two equal perspectives on this
one of which is like that could
absolutely be true like there seems to
be something about consciousness that
can't be explained in the physical world
there phenomena like when I've circled
or when I've done games sometimes I've
had these moments where I know things
about other people that I couldn't
possibly have known oh I'm or I'm like
in flow with the universe something is
coming through me rather than being me I
can't explain those moments and then
there's the rational side of me like my
parents were both doctors
I was raised super scientifically I'm
like very much a nerd I spend a lot of
my time just reading articles on science
and group dynamics and psychology and
stuff it underlies a lot of my work and
I also believe that if that there are
rules to everything in the universe and
if we understood all of those rules we
could understand why everything acts and
interacts the way it is like maybe
there's a spirit molecule that's causing
things some people think it's five of me
or DMT yeah maybe yeah and and it's
almost like I can hold the reality of
like empirical like deterministic
everything happens for a reason
everything can be explained by laws and
the sense of wheel on wondermint of like
probably in my lifetime all those things
aren't going to be figured out so like I
just get to experience that there's like
Wonder and beingness and things
happening through me and if both of
those realities are true and I think
they're coexisting I choose day to day
to live both of them and hold that sense
of wonder isn't even as I strive to
understand more that's cool yeah one
foot in one foot out you constantly have
your worldview run like that and then
what about do you think we're in a
simulation of the world can you say what
you mean by that are we in a simulation
you just want me to answer it yeah okay
I win a simulation
it begs the question of who would be
running the simulation if there is one
what I can say is I think that like who
we are and how we act is in some way
predetermined like everything that we've
experienced and done so far and been
taught and learned leads up to the
person that we are to the point where
like we couldn't do anything but what
we're doing right now which gives me a
lot of compassion for people because I'm
like I can't change who they were
I can only affect who they're going to
be and by shaming who they are right now
it's not gonna really help affect them
because they couldn't do anything else
so like in a sense we are in a
simulation we're in the simulation of
our own lives where these players that
are kind of playing out a role that's
been assigned to us but we're still
player one like I think we still get to
make choices we still get to find
congruence and we are in like a world
that's been built around us and that we
don't get choice over I have this this
Rumi poem that's actually tattooed on me
and the last line of it is your
boundaries or your quest the one thing
that we get to choose is where we stop
and where the world begins and I think
that's the one choice we have over the
simulation
and what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world oh man
there's so many
thank our capacity to choose and our
capacity for wonderment and
there's something incredibly poignant ly
beautiful about how painful that can be
like that awareness requires choice and
it requires staying awake all the time
and that's absolutely painful but like
ken wilber puts it like there's more
pain but there's less suffering let me
stay awake like that and there's such
richness and beauty to me and not
awakeness
this has been such a good effort really
fun so much fun uh-huh yeah thank you
thanks for all your work more authentic
relating and the revolution around the
world simulation to more simulation - I
love it I love it thanks everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking also do check
out the links in the bio that's author
or Gasol's auth team's org and enter the
living room link down there and a
sarah's youtube channel go subscribe to
watch those videos and have more
conversations with your friends your
family coworkers people online on social
media about these authentic relating
games go and download the manual make a
donation go and apply these to your life
as soon as possible get going with that
shoutout to ron vodkas for producing and
directing thank you very much rounding
for you she ate it and support the
artists entrepreneurs and spiritual
leaders around the world that you
believe and support them help them grow
simulations links are below our patreon
or PayPal or cryptocurrency link designs
with merchants get paid do all that cool
stuff and go build the future manifest
your dreams into the world we love you
very much thank you for tuning and we
will see you soon peace
[Music]